hey guys right great to be back hustle
con so basically for me hustling means
finding out the rules of the game that
you're playing and in how to break them
and put them in your favor now today I'm
going to talk about advertising but you
can apply this stuff to pretty much
anything it's just a way of thinking so
the reason that I'm going to be talking
about advertising today is because a few
years ago I pulled off my biggest hustle
and it got quite a lot of press but I've
never really talked before about kind of
how I did that so I wanted to talk today
about that and so this story starts just
me and my business partner at bungle we
were in a tiny office in London
just us - I like free interns and one
day I was just reading TechCrunch and I
saw this story saying hey there's this
incubator in San Francisco called Angel
pad and they're giving every company
that joins $100,000 and at the bottom it
said and there's one spot left for
somebody reading this article so I said
to my business plan I was like hey man
like imagine what would keep we could do
with $100,000 we should apply and he was
like nah man there's no point because we
looked at their Twitter account and they
were saying like oh we just got 2,000
applications in the last 24 hours and so
he's like well just get lost in the
noise you know but I was like come on
list at least let's give it a shot and
so we had this objective get into Angel
pad but they were telling us the way to
do it is to submit an application that's
that's we might sort of just like thrown
in the trash like it's not going to get
seen amongst 2,000 people you know we
had to find a way to stand out so what
we did is we looked okay who's the guy
running the incubator and as this guy
called Tomas and so start to think how
how can we get his attention
so we had the objective and now we had
this clear goal right how do we get to
masters attention and I'm going to
deviate from the story bit now because
if I'm like listening to a talk if I'm
reading a book I want to know I don't
want to just hear the story because that
can often be embellished a bit like I
want to hear the exact steps like what
did someone actually do in this scenario
and so hopefully I can kind of take you
into what my head what I was thinking at
that time so alright my goal is get on
Tomas his radar having that goal and
then the first step so as I said you can
apply this thinking to whatever if
you've got a goal you can apply this
thinking to whatever for me I was like I
god gives attention and the way I'm
going to do it I chose to use LinkedIn
advertising I chose this because you
know LinkedIn it's not as big as Google
or Facebook so potentially there might
be more ways to exploit it it's not as
established and also you know my
audience is there he's a user of
LinkedIn so once I've chosen the game if
you like I've got to find out the rules
of the game and in how I can break them
so if you've never seen a LinkedIn app
before basically like when you're
browsing LinkedIn you've got these ads
on the right side of the page that come
up a bit bit like Google AdWords and so
the first set of rules are to learn
about was the what are the rules of this
ad unit and now I just like love
breaking stuff I love breaking websites
I should I should have been a QA tester
probably so I just the way I found out
the vols is I just typed in random [__]
into the text boxes and see what you can
do with it and so I found the balls
they're basically yet to have a title
less than 25 characters an image like 50
pixels by 50 pixels and a short
description now a bonus I didn't
actually use this kind of loophole but
actually you could set the name as who
the advert was from from anyone so if
you wanted you
make an ad looking like it came from
Google that was just a loophole is that
and so the next set of rules was right
you create you've got your advert and
then the next set of rules is about how
you target your ad now LinkedIn lets you
do some really cool stuff you can target
by the company that someone's at and the
job title and basically as you layer on
this more specific targeting you see
that number on the right it shows you
how many people are going to see your ad
so me being me and as I said you want to
find out what are the rules I tried
running an ad just targeting super
specific so just job title CEO company
bungle so we're targeting a person of
one okay so that that number on the
right said one but it didn't it didn't
let you do that
it says like you know you've got a
target your ad to two more people you
you're not targeting enough people so I
added one more company
so now I'm targeting the CEO of bungle
or AOL so that's two people but it's
still saying you know that's not a big
enough set so I added one more company
and that's too small
one more nope
and so now we've got Microsoft Apple in
there as well as their five and then
keep laying on so now it's targeting six
and I would say it's not enough I'm not
sure how much time we got but I wanted
to keep I want to keep going through
this because this is the process that I
work through so I want to know what you
guys this is well we're going to find
out they're also targeting seven people
now okay what the hell it accepted it so
now we know the vols that we can target
seven people is the minimum number of
people you need to run an ad on LinkedIn
I don't know why they chose that number
maybe nobody had actually done this
process before but for me having found
out this what that meant is I now knew
how to target down to an individual
person because what I could do is I
could target hey the exact person let's
say the CEO of ungol and in what I could
do is I could just add in random people
that probably I'm not even going to see
my ad let's say like Bank of China or
Mexican TV studios something like I'd
have my person I want and in like six
random errs there I don't really care
and so the next bit was how to pay for
your ad now LinkedIn they recommended to
pay per person that clicks the ad they
recommended paying like $8 by the things
because I'm only targeting 7 people it
made sense to actually pay on the other
option they give which is CPM - paper
fouls and impressions I'm talking 7
people
and so I'm the they suggest that I bid
$2 52 per thousand people so that's why
I'm going to go with and the last set of
rules is the review process so basically
when you submit an ad on LinkedIn it
makes it says hey we're going to review
your ad
it'll take 24 hours and get back to you
and I'm some of the times when I
submitted and AD they rejected it but
what I found out is because you submit
it and then they take 24 hours it was a
manual process so what that meant is I
could just submit exactly the same ad
and someone else the next day would
review it and then often it went through
and also sometimes they didn't like like
if I was linking to a different website
they might say like hey we don't like
what you're linking to you know so what
I did is I used a URL shortener so I've
kind of put up the ad linking to one
page and then once they manually
approved it I just changed where that
link was pointing to
so to point it somewhere else now when
you're finding out the walls and stuff
it's also important to know the risks
you know of doing of trying to play the
game and so you know I didn't do
anything illegal not to illegal and the
main risk for me was that my account
could have got banned so just the
precaution I took against that was just
using I just created a fake camp to be
testing with you know now I'm going to
jump back to the story now so just
remind you I had been in London just me
and my business partner tiny office and
we've seen this TechCrunch article that
there's one spot left and so we needed
to get Tomas the guy that running it how
can we get his attention
so using these bids I found
why did is I created an app on LinkedIn
with a picture of his face so
this this fixing was doing the rules is
a 50 by 50 picture it's a title less
than 75 characters and then what I did
is because I can now have this ability
to target down to an individual person I
target it to him and people connected to
him so his colleagues his invested of
different investors etc and so basically
I've seen this TechCrunch post on
Thursday and I basically yes I read this
post so it's my best part that hey man
we should apply and then just kind of
quickly I'm hacked together this ad
campaign that same day and so basically
if you were browsing LinkedIn that day
and you're pledged to march to you
picture his face on the side of the
screen and when you click it it took you
to a landing page and I'm this was a
video that were just did in one take so
I just pulled out my phone I just died
filming my business partner so I was
like a game of respond phone we just do
this in one take and I was like pitch
into the phone why do we deserve this
last spot so I said when you'd land on
this page and click play is me and my
business where talking directly to Tomas
like Tomas in your background your
legend we deserve this last spot we
won't let you down this my phone number
this moment just give me a call
and so this was first day kind of just
went to sleep
and forgot about it and the next day I
just got this short email
also and and so basically had a phone
call with him and um because he said to
hey can we have a call so had this call
and he was like hey okay so I've seen
the advert you've got my attention it's
cool but take it down now it's like
everyone is calling me about this he
said he'd been on a flight from New York
to San Francisco he hadn't had email
access so he's got this flight and he's
checking his iPhone he had over 20
emails from people basically like dude
have you seen this video like these kids
really want to talk to you now
basically so he had this phone call on
the Friday and then it basically the
next week we had another Skype call and
then he basically said I guys
I decided who's got the last spot let's
have a final Skype call and we were like
man like we've got our team hit you have
to reject us on video can't you just
like phone us to reject us and he's like
no let's do a final Skype call and so we
had this call and is like all right guys
I've decided to take a risk you guys
have got the last spot and so we're like
high-fiving me on the office and he's
like okay but if you take this last spot
you've got to move to America
permanently because I've invested in
some companies before where they just go
straight back to their own country and
you know the investors don't like it's
tough to like yep that's fine we'll move
to America and so we've seen the ad on
Thursday this was the next Thursday and
like that's great well it starts on
Monday so just get the first flight out
here so that's basically how I end up in
America now the the best the best thing
about this ad is potentially how much it
cost so this is I said I've run some
talking his friends but one targeting to
Mars
cost one cent
because I was paying per thousand
impressions but five people saw it two
people clicked it and that was Tomas so
that caused one sin now just to show
that this wasn't kind of just luck just
some other examples of how I use this
hack I was just really asked all that
color at the time had just raised like
40 million so we're like okay can we
target the CEO of color and do something
so my objective target the CEO bill is
Bill and so we ran an ad with Bill's
face on it plug to Google and then got
an email from Bill as well as like hey
I've seen your ad we've got an ad agent
because we were doing videos at the time
says like we've all got an agency but
you know we'll try and let's see if we
can slot you in and he enjoyed me to his
team and that cost $2 78 let's get to
Bill and in Rovio you know speed mobile
gaming company so we're like I can we
contact Rovio's CEO he's gone Michael
head now we didn't get to Michael
directly but we've got one of the VP's
of Rovio sent us an email saying like
hey guys smile ad and we started talking
to them and that cost $3 24 and then we
were like what about Spotify can we get
them as a client and so we just put up
an ad saying I want Spotify the client
and um and then ya got an email from
Spotify saying hey you guys got our
attention and we actually got Spotify as
a client but that one was bit more
expensive it was $16
okay so to summarize this was the
different steps I took now there's no
point we can't all in the audience like
recreate step for step this advertising
bit otherwise they'll definitely ban us
all and you know that was a while ago so
LinkedIn have changed their systems but
hopefully you can kind of use those
philosophies to hack whatever system
you're coming up to whether that's
applying for a job you know if you're if
you've got a job they tell you just
submit a job application you might as
well just throw your CV in the trash
like that's not going to get people's
attention the way that you do this is by
looking at what's your objective was the
game that I'm playing and then finding
out the rules of the game and how to
break them so this isn't just limited to
LinkedIn advertising I kind of take this
thinking into lots of stuff that I do
and so these are my contact details and
I'd love to hear how you guys kind of
use this thinking and what kind of hacks
you come up with thanks a lot
so don't if anyone had any questions
thanks jack if you have any questions
please come to the front
Hey
great time I was just wondering if you
had any other stories of something
you've hacked in there in a similar
manner any upper hacks yes so ah well I
I've done some other hacks but like idea
packs I have that haven't tried yet
because I don't had no objective would
be Facebook advertising is quite
interesting because what you can do is
you can target people by email address
so you can upload like a list of email
addresses so you could think how you
could use that thinking with Facebook
because what you do is you just have the
one email address of who you want to
target and it's a load of junk email
addresses that you don't care about so
then it's how do I get that one
individual I also kind of use this kind
of thinking for like Amazon so when I'm
doing stuff like my account got banned
on Amazon and so but because I like buy
so much stuff and I would turn it and so
I just like if I wanted to buy like a
pair of headphones what I'd do is just
buy like the top 10 selling headphones
on Amazon try all 10 and then return 9
they really like that but so basically
the way with Amazon why did is found the
rules of Amazon how do they see an
account and so basically what I did is I
found basically a way to be undetected
on Amazon which is you can set up like a
virtual computer so I'm using another
computer that has different email
address and in a different IP address
etc you there's ways you can like mask
your phone number and in you just by but
you you know there's gift cards you buy
it like Safeway and stuff then obviously
they can't track you back to your credit
card so basically it's just finding out
the rules of the game how does Amazon
track you is your credit card it's your
phone number it's your address and it's
your IP address and stuff so how do we
break those rules credit card get like a
gift card so they can't track you phone
number you can use something like Twilio
is really cheap email you can just use a
fake email address address I just change
the address a bit yeah and so the same
with Netflix Netflix gives you like a 30
day or 60 day trial so but it's it's
limited by the address so what I do is
say I'm one two three fourth street I
just do one two three fourth Street unit
a unit B unit C and so you just keep
getting free trial awesome thanks so
much
hi have you ever done a hack on somebody
and really made the mad and wished you
hadn't because there were negative
consequences well yes so doing that
LinkedIn advertising again part of the
bit that I said in there was knowing the
risks so if I'm doing these hacks I've
at least got to know the risks that I'm
going through so one we targeted a
dating website like match.com and we use
their logo and targeting it and we got
like a cease and desist letter and they
also emailed LinkedIn a bit but what we
did is again it's no universe like see
some deceased they're not this highly
likely they're going to sue you unless
you like really annoy them you know so
we just took it right live sinners
season seized an ad but then we actually
kind of just take turn it back on the
lawyer we were like no dude this is only
people talking at your company it's not
too public
can you entrust to someone else on your
team who does BD instead of and then
they did so it thinks I think is just
about knowing the risks and not pushing
it too far you know you just got to know
the risk to what you're doing and just
knowing if you can take on those risks
and not going so far that it has
negative consequences
thanks Kevin
ok so I have a question what if you want
to get into some program but you have no
idea who is the organizer you know
nobody there and you cannot find all the
emails you don't just don't know
anything like who is running this thing
what you can do to like heck I mean you
should be able to find out something
about them you know like I didn't know
Thomas is the email address or anything
I just went on like crunchbase or that
TechCrunch the article said like hey
Tomas is running it so I think it'll be
quite rare that you can't at least find
the name of someone doing it like 500
startups you'd see dave McClure like Y
Combinator Sam Outman you can just like
what you do is you just Google the thing
and see what people are mentioned as
being involved with it you know
like that that's what we did is just
reading different tech press and stuff
okay
thank you yes I wanted to kind of add on
that last question
sometimes just physical surveillance
tracking someone down meeting them on
the street is the best way to do it you
know find out where corporate
headquarters is walk up hey I'll try
that one next time so uh so I'm sure you
use many tools to help you with these
hacking what would you say are your top
three tools like web plug-in that allows
you to track when the emails are open
stuff like that uh so Twilio can be
quite off-putting because when they put
out the ads they're like hey talk to
your developer or something about it
it's actually quite simple to use like
once you get started and so Twilio is
really cool for just basically how I use
Twilio as well is you know when you sign
up to stuff online and in they ask for
your phone number sometimes it requires
your phone number and then just you get
a random cold calls from appetizers like
later on basically I use Twilio I
basically set up a number and it just
goes straight to voicemail so whenever
I'm signing up for something I just put
in my Twilio number and it will go
straight to voicemail so it doesn't
bother me at all you know so I like
Twilio boomerang for Gmail is like the
main tool that I love because you can
let schedule what time an email goes and
stuff there's one called mail track
which is just it's kind of like whatsapp
for email like it shows when they opened
the emails and stuff there's lots of
different ones that I like like I use
product hunt quite a lot so find
different tools and stuff on there are
some things we have time for one more
question if anyone has one
I'd like to say teespring because he's
speaking a bit later but it's not but I
could I could basically they could
probably run the whole business just off
me I have quite a lot of t-shirts got
thanks for the talk so I was wondering
on the conversion rate of a successful
hack when you choose an objective in a
weapon of choice how many times you go
and learn like the risks and the game's
rules of the game and then you can't
figure out a way to game the system
um I mean for me
yeah LinkedIn apt I wasn't really
expecting to find that break for you
know like it was just messing around
with it I think he's kind of thinking
about something that you could apply to
other stuff like the in LinkedIn
advertising I was able to use it with
Tomas because I'd already been
experimenting with it before so I think
it's good if you can the way I do it is
I just target systems that I could use
more than once you know like I wouldn't
find a hack specific to Angel pad i I'd
be target I just be playing around with
different systems and then even if I
don't have an objective at that time
just by playing around then if I see
something come up you know I saw that ad
and in the same day I could create the
ad campaign so I think by targeting kind
of general bits like I'd be interested
messing around more with like Facebook
Ads and all these different other ad
products that come up you know yeah
that's why I think it's like some
genesis quicker on question how much of
your free time do you spend learning
about systems
what's procrastinating isn't it so
that's what I do a lot is like
I mess around on the Internet thank you
very much thank great thank you